just on august 31st august 30th a guy
you guys may know his name is jared
kushner took a flight from
israel to uae crossing palestinian you
know
and trump had folks from palestine and
you know netanyahu they're renegotiating
working together what happened that was
just eight months ago nine months ago
august 31st and everybody this is
ridiculous 25 years
can't believe trump this temperamental
guy was able to unify everybody
by the way again that's august 31st of
2020.
fast forward where we are today the the
two
going back and forth obviously there's
deep-rooted issues you just kind of told
the history of where it's at and what
netanyahu did and what others did
here's my biggest concern so biden calls
netanyahu
and biden calls the leader of palestine
hamas he has a conversation with them
right phone call
with them when a phone call is being
made
by the most important man in the world
who is the president of the united
states
and they blow you off guess what that
means
you have no influence you're a nobody
who blew up biden calls netanyahu
and palestine saying stop it stop doing
what you're doing
neither one of them listen to them what
does that tell you
there is no influence what do you think
the phone calls sounded like i think
it's i understand what you guys are
going through i think it's good you guys
need to stop it this is not good people
are dying children are dying they're
like uh
okay bye what are you talking about
fasfa would think about the phone call
of the guy that was the most hated man
in the world just about a year ago
let's say if that was happening today
trump made the phone call what is trump
going to say
i just want to let you know if i hear
one more rocket going i swear to god
you're gonna get 25
sanction put on you for six months do it
i dare you go ahead
go ahead do it i dare you okay okay okay
mr
president we don't want to go to that
situation and we're not saying this to
you we're just saying
no no do it again go ahead and do it
again that is the kind of stuff
in moments like this where you realize
and you miss a guy
who actually had a backbone and people
feared him who
actually had the negotiation ability to
challenge us
god knows there was a lot of other
things that he was doing that was
pissing a lot of people off and
creating a lot of unnecessary uh what's
the word i'm looking for tension that
was not not needed right
but fast if trump made that phone call
today i would have happened here's the
other question i got for you
here's the other question i got for you
how instrumental was jared kushner in
this entire deal
how very much so by the way kushner is
not a republican people think he's a
republican he's not a republican he's an
independent at best
is what kushner is he's probably a
democrat his brother and his wife are
certainly a democrat what i'm saying is
he's not a republican
he is not a republican he's just
following trump he's a you know he's
he's a guy that gets things done
that's kushner goes from real estate to
all of a sudden negotiating a deal
between israel and palestine who are you
like
you think it's just a real estate
transaction the guy and he doesn't even
want the recognition right
so here's my question for you follow up
to what you just said hey
mr biden president biden this matters to
you a lot phenomenal thank you for being
such a man that cares about what's going
on in palestine and uh
and israel if it matters so much to you
have you made the phone call to a guy
named donald and a man named jared who
actually were able to negotiate a piece
have you if you care about all these
people that are getting killed and are
being bombed
have you made that phone call to say hey
donald what should we do here hey jared
what did you do here this is not about
ego here this is if people's lives
really matter guess who you call you
call your ex
you call the husband of your wife that
you were with even though you can't
stand this guy say listen
my kids are living with your kids we got
a problem going out listen you and i
don't like each other i fully get it but
in this situation we both like our kids
yes or no perfect
what do we need to do in this situation
here because one of your kids got caught
smoking weed and my kids thinking about
doing the same thing as well they were
only 13 14 years old
you and i need to have a sit down
together this is when you realize
who's a true diplomat this is when you
realize who's a true negotiator
this is when you realize who's a real
ambassador this is when you realize
who's a true statement that
cares about the lives of people and if
you truly do
it's not a phone call to netanyahu and
it's not a phone call to them it's a
phone call to a guy named donald trump
it's a phone call to a guy named
uh jared kushner fyi i want you to
visualize this
who wins in this situation let me paint
a picture and i gotta go because
caroline's here telling me i gotta go
i wanna paint a picture to you next week
today's what today's thursday what is
today
today's tuesday this week what day you
see
on friday or thursday biden on stage
with kushner and trump and kamala
hear me out on stage they get up and
they say
following statement folks we may
disagree on god knows how many different
things
but if there's one thing we agree on is
we don't like to see the violence that's
taking place in israel and palestine
right now president trump and president
biden and i were on the same page
to have to stop this if you're watching
this right now netanyahu and palestine
this needs to stop
or else dot dot dot dot we're asking for
the support
because this matters that much if that
took place this week
who wins you're smiling because you're
actually seeing it if that took place
this week the world would win
the world wins but on a serious note who
actually wins bidenwood
biden wins not trump yes if biden makes
that call
biden wins and the world's going to say
he would look like a true diplomat but
do you think it will happen
no and that's why i'm still probably
because the place we're at all of this
stuff
that's going on in palestine all of this
stuff that's going on in israel and
palestine could be
solved if the leaders truly cared about
this make the damn phone call to the
guys that were able to broker this deal
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you